now to alberta and the arrests of 13
people in the seizure of long guns
handguns body armor and ammunition by
the rcmp who also allege the driver of a
semi-truck accelerated towards police
swerving at the last minute heather urix
west is near milk river tonight heather
this is a serious escalation take us
through what the police say they seized
donna police say they executed a search
warrant early this morning on three
trailers in cootes police say they
received information on sunday that
there was a group of protesters or
people associated with the protest i
should say who had access to weapons and
were also willing to use force against
police should police move in to disrupt
this blockade now that search revealed a
number of weapons 13 long guns were
seized as well as handguns ammunition
high capacity magazines body armor
and a machete there was also an incident
on sunday involving two vehicles
associated with the protest police say a
large tractor as well as a semi-trailer
worked together to try and ram a police
vehicle
the truth is is that there's a heavy
stash of weapons and these weapons were
brought by people who had the intent on
causing harm
after this blockade in alberta is now
into its third week costing the economy
an estimated 44 million dollars a day
what is premier jason kenny saying about
it
yeah the premier had stronger words
about the need to end this blockade
today he also said that his government
is assisting rcmp he says that the
government has helped to procure all of
the necessary
equipment and services needed to move
commercial vehicles from the highway
the ongoing blockade of our borders and
our highways at coots will no longer be
tolerated and now that this
very delicate security challenge has
been resolved successfully by the police
as i say broader enforcement measures
will commence
and police also say there was another
incident today involving someone
suspected to be associated with the
protest trying to run down a police
officer so a very tense situation i can
tell you that the mood has definitely
become more hostile definitely towards
the media down here but even in the last
few hours we're also seeing uh sort of
the the camp the crowd here in milk
river start to thin out people are
deciding to pack up and leave so perhaps
some hopeful news there but the border
does still remain blocked
still closed to traffic so this
situation is definitely far from over
donna
all right heather urex west near milk
river alberta thanks